No,
it's very fun.
It's like terminator,
Terminator.
No,
I just liked the scan things and then
something or wonder woman in a bionic
woman.
But,
but something attracts the attention and
I zero in.
And it's funny because it can be
millions of objects and uh,
um,
so at that point it's almost irrational.
What attracts me about that object?
But usually there's something,
you know,
I go in and dig deeper.
Um,
so it's not a first impression.
It's not superficial.
It's almost as if the work
communication.
Sorry if I sound a little new agey here
at animistic,
but it really works that way.
And uh,
what I do,
I spend my day without thinking scanning
things and uh,
I,
I already noticed your shirt and I
already noticed,
you know,
I already noticed everything about you
without even thinking it could be a good
detective perhaps,
you know,
um,
and uh,
uh,
and what attracts me in an object is
some sort of communication that the
designer already instilled in the
object.
Because you know,
what,
if you notice today,
the objects that are considered most
interesting are the ones that are in
doubt by the designer with some sort of
a,
how can I say,
some sort of grabbing a element that
attracts more than your attention,
you know,
that attracts really your interest.
And this happens with all sorts of
objects.
That's why,
you know,
I was doing an interview once,
I was interviewing Johnny Ive,
who's the head designer for apple.
He hardly ever gives interviews and I
was really lucky that,
you know,
we're friends,
but you know,
I convinced him to give an interview,
but we started talking about this,
about the communication,
um,
that objects have with people.
Because to me one of the most stunning
features of apple computers is the
little breathing light.
You know,
the little breathing light that tells
you that the computer is leaping,
is asleep and not turned off.
I mean,
that's amazing.
It makes you think that the computer has
a heart,
you know?
So it's this little touches that people
noticed subliminally that differentiate
certain objects from others.